[音楽]
me
tod 2
[拍手]
ああああああああああ
r
[音楽]
ああああああ
ああああああああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
r
[拍手]
普段あんまり一人引かないものですから
ちょっと緊張しました
三味線の音を初めて聞いた方いらっしゃい
ますでしょうかちょっと白秋していただけ
たらと思います
じゃあ聞いたことあった人
[拍手]
ちょっとあの私が想定していたよりも聞い
たことがある人が多かったの
嬉しく思っています
8一概に三味線といってもこの計上した
ものが
3種類あることをご存知でしょうか
あのギターにも暗スティックギターとか
遅れと改暦きたとかいろんな種類がある
ように三味線も種類があります
ジャンルによって使う三味線が違ってきて
います
一般の方がマーズ三味線と言って
思い浮かべられるのは津軽三味線だと思う
んですけれども津軽三味線は三味線の中で
も一番大きな三味線を使います
私がやっている長唄というジャンルはこの
細棹三味線というのを使って演奏いたし
ます
この
三味線の音色が10年後には危険なくなる
かもしれません
年前の朝日新聞の記事にこの国産方楽器の
年間製造数のグラフが掲載されました
手を見ますと
コロナよりだいぶ以前から
現象の it をたどっているのがわかり
ます
時によると
プロの演奏家
アマチュアの愛好かー
それからは楽器店方が起点の3者が
それぞれ減少してしまって原材料の調達も
混乱になり悪循環に陥ってしまっていると
いうふうに書かれていました
事実普段三味線にあまりなじみのない大学
生に者店についてどんなイメージを持って
いるのかという風に聞いてみました
そうするとスキーが高いであるとかよく
わからない
おじいさんおばあさんがやっている
イメージ
日常生活からかけ離れていて普段触れる
チャンスもあまりない
こんな回答が返ってきました
これは
の方々のイメージそのものなのではないか
というふうに思いました
彼らは残さなければいけない価値がある
ものをが消えてしまう危機感もあるという
風にも言ってくれました
本には多くを語らず空気を読むことが美徳
とされてきたそんなあの傾向があります
けれどもそれによって伝えなければいけ
ないことが伝わり消えていないのではない
か
それが分断の一つの原因になってしまって
いるのではないかというふうに私は思い
ます
今日はまず
長唄三味線について伝えることから始めて
いきたいとおもいます
まず三味線なんですけれども
このように3本の弦が張ってあります太さ
の品を3本の弦が張ってあってそしてこの
この太鼓の部分のことをどうと言います裏
にも皮が張ったりのでまさにタイプですね
三味線はゲイナー機と違ってがミックスさ
れたがキダルというふうに言えます
そして
三味線には全くフォルダーがないのでみー
の手一本で三味線を支えています
左手はもう話し合った
音が出る
なので車3世匹の兎ては見えますかね
ちょっと惚れちゃってるんですけどあの
常々高重心をかけて三味線をギュッと
押さえて
大全体で延焼している
感じになります
なのでお客様のほうからご覧になると
金屏風の前に座って最も鈴過ぎにあの
静かに弾いているようなイメージをお持ち
かと思うんですけれども実はかなり高
筋トレに使うような感じで演奏しているの
で私は写メ成否はアスリートだというふう
に思っています
さて私のやっているなだ歌について少しお
話をしたいと思います
永田は今から300年くらい前に歌舞伎の
音楽として発生したもので主に歌舞伎舞踊
の伴奏として発展してきた歴史を持つ
劇場音楽です
通常このように歌数に三味線数2時に曲に
よっては対向おやつ済みなののおはやしと
一緒にが発送します
これは江戸時代に
いいかーとかマイクが無かった時代に聞き
場という広い空間で演奏するために大人数
で演奏する必要があったためです
今でも国立二地上や歌舞伎座などの大きな
吉祥では歌住人三味線12ぐらいの大編成
でマイクだして s をしています
三味線
あるいは太鼓鼓
笛などさまざまな書で演奏するということ
はちょっとオーケストラ b に入ってい
ますよね
でもオーケストラと大きく違う点が1つ
あります
はいっ
相談です正解です記者がいないんですねで
しかもみんな真っ正面を向いているのでお
互いのメンバーの
表情であるとか
途中でアイコンタクトをするとかっていう
こともできないので
みんな光照明を見て演奏しているんです
けれどもなのに
一糸乱れで炎症ができるのはなぜか
ピタッとするのはなぜかということなん
ですけれどもそれは三味線はそれぞれ座る
ポジションによって役割が決まっています
まず
歌の隣に座っている三味線のことを立てた
て三味線と呼びます
の人はコンサートマスターが役割を
になっているんですね
この人が店舗を決めている全体の責任者
です
具体的に言うとかけ合意を歌ねかけたりお
囃子にかけたり一緒に弾いてる者店にかけ
たりしながら bd をしていきます
強いリーダーシップが必要なポジションに
なります
縦三味線の隣が湧き者店
マティ三味線というのは縦三味線のことを
サポートしつつ
立三味線が引きたように弾いてくれるよう
には気に伝達すぐあまくまきーじゃなくて
連れの人に伝達する役割があります
それだけではなくてた停車店に何かこう
トラブルがあった場合意図が演奏中に切れ
てしまったりとか
そういった場合に
縦三味線に変わって延焼しなければいけ
ない
とっさの判断力が必要な結構重要な
ポジションです
演奏を生かすも殺すのは機4台と言われて
いましては気にするとかなり緊張いたし
ます
人目以降は連れというふうに言いますでは
脇の人から伝わってきたて三味線の息に
合わせて演奏するのがお仕事です
息を合わせるというのは日本語でも一致
団結するとか
協力し合うというような意味があります
けれども
この場合の息を合わせがまさにブレスする
ところを合わせるんですね
ので
私がデビューしたての頃に
先輩からちょっとそこ行きしないでみたい
な
人以上に変にを経て体こんなことがあるん
ですけど
それはまさにあの
ブレスするタイミングが違っていたからで
別にずっと行きしないでくれって言われた
わけじゃなくていきしなかったら死ん
じゃうんですけれどもブレスのタイミング
を合わせるようにということを教えてくれ
ていました
8つれ今これ一人ですけど物で大人数の
編成などずーっと連れが何も続くわけです
で三味線弾きはデビューをすると端っこ
から順に縦のセンターにだんだん近づいて
いけるように精進をしていきます
一番端っこに座っている人のことを止めと
言います止めはえーっ一番味っ子だから
ピュイを雛ちゃんが座っているわけでは
なくてですね
音の伝達というのは離れれば離れるほど
遅れてきますので端っこにいる人が一番
ひき肉わけですね
なので縦の人の幸
意向をくみ取れるだけのうさ医療がないと
いけない誰のために座った人がピシッと
引いてくれるとしまった言いそうになり
ます
このように
三味線は座る位置によってポジションに
打ってそれぞれのミッションがありますの
で
このミッションを随行することでいい演奏
ができます
長唄はまさにチーム戦だというふうに
言えると思います
この長唄三味線が聞けなくなってしまうか
もしれない危機にある今
伝統芸能の世界にいう我々演奏家は
受け身体勢ではなく自らさまざまな
アプローチをしていく必要があるという
ふうに思っています
私は先ほど大学生が入ってくれたスキーが
高いであるとかよくわからないとか触れる
チャンスがあまりない
そんな賛美線のネガティブイメージを覆す
ような取り組みをして言っています
全18年に
初心者向けのサークルを作りました
これサークルのお稽古風景なんですけれど
も
な風にみんなで集ってを携行しています
サークル発足当初メンバーを募集するため
に
広く一般の方々に聴いていただけるように
と思って精霊施設の一角で三味線のライブ
をやってみたんですけれども
たく集客できませんでした
まあ想定はしていたんですが改めて
昔農し三味線長唄に対する認知度の低さに
愕然としました
そこで
へ
落語であるとか
長唄の局員ちなんだ街歩きであるとか個別
のアクティビティとコラボレーションする
企画を立てて地道に演奏を聴いてもらう
ことを続けてようやくメンバーが集まる
ようになりました
傾向を始めると3今皆が使っています
けれども三味線が必要になってきます自分
の三味線が必要になってきます
けれども
いきなり高額な三味線を購入するのは
ハードルが高い
て
安いお値段安価でレンタでできるレンタル
三味線を使うことにしました
今ディーンサブスクリプションですかね
これによりユーザビリティーが格段に
上がって気軽にお稽古を始める人が増え
ました
シュートに2を急行重ねタート
疲労機会を設けております
これは
神田明神なんですけれども神田明神の境内
で
奉納プロレスというのがやってましてそれ
もちょっと面白いなと思うんですがその
プロレスのリングの上で営巣してみません
かっていう風にお声がかかりまして
演奏しました
s のリングのべって乗ったことあるかと
言いますか
アヴェダうんあんまり
あの乗れる場所じゃないと思うんですけど
あのってみたら意外とふかふかしていて
ですねよく考えてみたらこう何ファンとか
なに対応された時に硬いと気がしちゃうで
柔らかくなってるんだと思うんですけど
結構船酔い状態になるなぁと思いなあこの
流れだからひいていました
中々できない経験をさせてもらったと思っ
てます
これは8 jr 御茶ノ水の行き前広場で
弾いた時のものです
ちょっと帽子かぶってますけど
8月でしたかね真夏の炎天下の
日中症の危険と戦いながら命がけで演出を
しました
これなんでこんなことしているのかという
と
長唄は普段劇場やホールに来ないと聞け
ないものだ
という風に思っていましてあの世銀の方も
持っていらっしゃるんじゃないかと思い
ます
なので
こちらから出向いて言ってですね私はこの
三味線の押し売り長唄の修理っていうふう
に言っているんですけれども
普段聞いたことがない方に聴いて
いただけるようにと思って松中で営巣する
活動をしています
永田サークルなんですが三味線の習得と
いう意味ではかなり時間がかかるものなん
ですけれどもこのサークルは
長唄の三味線のスキルアップのために集っ
ているのではなく
合奏を楽しむことを目的としてみんな
集まってきています
ので
三味線スキルはさりながら
お互いをリスペクトしあったりとか気遣っ
たりとか譲り合ったりとかそういう
コミュニケーションが非常に大切になって
きています
今コロナとなってですね伝統芸能の世界で
も youtube 大流行ですみんな
配信始めました
今まではには考えられなかったことで
大きな変革の時になってきています
変わるということは時代に合わせて柔軟に
変わるということは非常に大事なことだと
思いますけれども音質が変わることでは
ないと思っています
私がやってきているこういういろんな
アプローチ
もう新しいアプローチも長唄三味線の
世代や
生活環境やあるいは国籍そういったものを
乗り越えたコミュニケーションツールに
なり得るそういった長唄三味線の本質は
芦原ないそれを伝えていっているものだと
思っています
伝統は
伝統を守っていくということはかたくなに
変わらずそれを続けていくということでは
なくて大切なものを守りながら変化に順応
していく
それが大事なのではないかというふうに
思います
これは
先日
茨城県の鹿島神宮で奉納演奏やはりしまし
たその時の様子です
私のこの活動に共感してくれた仲間がでい
まして
茨城県でも同じようなサークルが今年
生まれました
これは疲労機械でこの時に10人くらいの
メンバーでいそうしたんですけれども
制服着てますが10代の若者中学生高校生
も交じって椅子をしてくれています
若い
次世代につなげていくための学生向けの
ワークショップなども増やしています
今日のお話を聞いていただいて
少しでも三味線に興味を持っていただけ
たらなというふうに思っています興味を
持っていただけたらまず三味線を手にとっ
て合奏種楽しみを知っていただけたらと
思っていますありがとうございました
[拍手]